welcome to the show which is still
taking place in this blank void TV's
greatest celebration of whiteness since
Frasier it's clearly been another brutal
week with the occasional bright spot
like learning Judi Dench's apparently
doing tick-tock dances with her grandson
over FaceTime hard yes on that I think
we all just learned a lot there one Judi
Dench can hit the wall like a
pro to her grandson might be ed Sheeran
and three life's getting pretty weird on
earth right now but sadly we have to put
all that aside and turn straight to our
main story this week various corn that's
actually surprised I thought we were
gonna talk about something depressing
but instead you know wait a minute
coronavirus is that you you sneaky
little bugger I should have known it's
always you coronavirus you're an
absolute nightmare
the fact is Kovac 19 is still dominating
the news every day and it's hard to keep
up with all the information about it to
say nothing of the misinformation here's
the myth you need to microwave your mail
to kill the COBIT 19 virus mail is not
food and you can't cook it garlic does
have some antimicrobial properties but
there is absolutely no evidence that it
kills covet 19 adults are now buying
breast milk because some believe that it
can protect them from covet 19 do not
that is not gonna help you no no it
isn't you should absolutely not be
buying other people's breast milk to
protect you from the coronavirus not
only will it not work you're taking it
away from the babies and the perverts
who genuinely need it now unfortunately
regarding this virus is
widespread and people are acting on it
just this week we saw protests all over
the country against stay-at-home orders
and some of the attendees like at
Michigan's operation gridlock seemed
motivated by very questionable
information what about concerns for
safety in spreading this virus and
like killing more people
I think it's all hate we're against
these big corporates that are trying to
wreck in all these dollars who created
the disease and not now want to make
people pay for the Cure kills more
people than this does
okay what's worrying about that other
than absolutely everything is that you
may have even heard some of those
arguments from people you're related to
or people you love which can
incidentally be two very distinct groups
polls show that when asked about the
death rate forty percent of Americans
believe Kovach 19 is less deadly or just
as deadly as the flu which it's not it
is many times deadlier comparing the
coronavirus to the flu is like comparing
Jeffrey Dahmer to OJ Simpson I'm not
saying Oh J is great I'm just saying he
wouldn't even filled up Damas vegetable
drawer and bad information is not only
frustrating to the extent that it
motivates people to ignore stay-at-home
measures it's both dangerous and could
actually end up forcing us to stay at
home for longer and if you're thinking
how can people possibly believe
like that that's actually our story
tonight the bad information flying
around about this virus and the places
that people are getting it from because
there are a lot of media bubbles out
there and getting a glimpse outside of
the one that you're in can be
eye-opening for example if you're not a
regular viewer of televangelist and
humble private jet farmer Kenneth
Copeland you might not know that he took
care of Kovac 19 weeks ago commenting on
you you are destroyed forever
and you'll never be back okay
setting aside his crew of the four we
Gnaeus type men of all time spitting all
over the place is not gonna cure
anything unless your plan is to give the
corona virus the corona virus in which
case best of luck to you although I do
understand why Copeland is so determined
to end this pandemic if I only had a few
weeks until my tragically of his hair
dye started to fade I'd be anxious that
my color is to be allowed to leave their
home too especially if I'd already
claimed on my actual website that my
unnaturally dark hair at the age of 82
was simply the result of standing in the
mirror and saying glory to God
hair grow dark brown thick be in the
name of Jesus ball spots no my point is
there's a lot at stake here for Kenneth
Copeland but the televangelists world is
just one of the many bubbles there's
also an ecosystem of conspiracy theories
like the false belief that the virus was
caused by 5g network something that led
people to set fire to cell towers in the
UK this month which is just ridiculous
although not as ridiculous as the fact
that those flaming towers almost
certainly still offered better coverage
than AT&T oh that's right business daddy
you thought a pandemic would bring us
together of course not
our feud must be an essential service
because it's still in business seriously
though
Biddy I do hope you're safe and healthy
I can't wait to talk to you as soon as
this is over and as soon as I can get
more than one bar of service but here in
the u.s. one of the biggest and most
robust bubbles is the right-wing media
sphere it's dominated by some enormous
ly powerful individuals not just on TV
but importantly on conservative talk
radio where the most powerful host is
undeniably Rush Limbaugh a man with
millions of listeners a Presidential
Medal of Freedom and almost certainly a
room in his basement that his
housekeeper isn't allowed to go into
even well into the outbreak Limbaugh has
been spouting some fabulously wrong
information here he is on March 11th
this coronavirus they're just all of
this panic is just not warranted this
I'm telling you when I when I tell you
when I've told you that this virus is
the common cold when I said that it was
based on the number of cases it's also
based on the kind of virus this is why
do you think this is cough in 19 this is
the 19th corona virus they're not
uncommon okay no rush just no no to you
claiming Kovac 19 got its name because
it was the 19th corona virus that's not
true it's called that because it was
first identified in 2019 you gigantic
potato but also no 2 the virus being the
common cold
no 2 this be not uncommon no to your
gold microphone no to your browser being
open to the Drudge Report no to your
logo that looks like two pairs of
breasts are in a fight no to the
mysterious can on your desk which I can
only assume is Pam original cooking
spray but most of all no - you're stupid
quarantine beard you look like if Santa
was me too - kicked out of the North
Pole and forced to move to a condo in
Tampa with all linoleum floors I hate it
the problem is many in conservative
media I found it easy to fold this virus
into narratives that they've been
carefully building up for decades
Limbaugh has spent years pushing his
four corners of deceit which consists of
government academia science and the
media which unfortunately happened to be
the four most important groups to listen
to during a public health crisis and I
understand why he'd so that doubt if you
establish your show as the sole outlets
worth trusting that gives you a lot of
power and he's not alone in utilizing
that technique Fox News's recurrent
pitch to his audience has been that it
will tell you the true story that elites
and the mainstream media are trying to
hide and that's how some of their hosts
played this virus initially as a
hysterical attack by the media to derail
the president with segments titled
coronavirus hysteria liberal media hoax
backfires and Trump confronts the panic
pushers and when people started dying
and that arguments became harder to sell
the network seemed to pivot from trying
to downplay the warnings to downplaying
the deaths today thankfully zero people
in the United States of America have
died from the corona virus zero we have
six deaths from the corona virus 18,000
deaths from the flu
people have died that's tragic but it's
tini 22 people have been killed those
numbers pale in comparison to the number
of flu cases over this flu season an
estimated 60,000 Americans will die from
the corona virus according to the CDC in
2018 61 thousand Americans died of the
annual flu the fact of the matter is we
have people dying
we have 45,000 people a year die from
automobile accidents 480 thousand from
cigarettes 360,000 here from swimming
pools but we don't shut the country down
for there
oh thanks not a medical doctor fill a
quick thing there though the annual US
death toll from swimming pools isn't
actually 360,000 they're not killing
almost a Cleveland every year the total
number of drownings period is around
4000 also if swimming pools were killing
360,000 people here and you could
contract a swimming pool on a trip to
the grocery store we might want to think
about shutting them down until we worked
out what the was going on and look
a lot of people underestimated the
danger of this virus early on but folks
were still doing it not just as the
death toll mounted but even as behind
the scenes their own company was
suspending non-essential business travel
and encouraging employees to cancel all
in-person meetings and summits and
conduct a business via Skype or by phone
because and this is true they only
pretend to believe these things on
television for money and the problem is
our current president isn't just the
subject of this misinformation he is as
we all know also the target of it often
pulling his talking points directly from
what he sees late last month a popular
conservative narrative became that it
was time to reopen the economy and Fox's
steve hilton encapsulated it like this
you know that famous phrase the cure is
worse than the disease that is exactly
the territory we are hurtling towards
now I'm pretty sure Trump saw that
because just a couple of hours after
that segment aired he tweeted we cannot
let the Cure be worse than the problem
itself and the next day couldn't seem to
stop saying it we cannot let the Cure be
worse than the problem itself we're not
gonna let the
you'll be worse than the problem that's
why I talk about the cure being worse
than the problem we can't have the Cure
be worse than the problem when I say the
cure and the cure could be worse than
the problem itself right that's what I
can't let that happen it's pretty
depressing to see the president just
parroting what he heard on TV the night
before and if he's gonna do that the
very least he could do is pick a better
show than Steve Hilton's the next
revolution why not go with below-deck
sailing yacht that way we get to hear
the president the United States tell us
about how Adam the chef is at ease and
how Madison needs to understand her role
in the interior pecking order and start
listening to her chief stew because
Jenna does not need to take her yes
it wouldn't be helpful during a pandemic
but at least it wouldn't be actively
harmful that is what is infuriating here
even though Trump has access to the
country's top experts he's still getting
advice from watching TV and not just on
talking points but on medicine take
hydroxychloroquine it's a drug commonly
used for conditions like rheumatoid
arthritis and lupus and it got a huge
boost in mid-march as a potential
coronavirus treatment from Tucker
Carlson's show early evidence suggests
that chloroquine that's a cheap
anti-malaria drug may be effective in
treating coronavirus gregory regan o is
an advisor the Stanford University
School of Medicine and he joins us
tonight a well controlled peer-reviewed
study carried out by the most eminent
infectious disease specialists in the
world shown a 100% you're right jury
against coronavirus I only know what
you're telling me but I do know it's
very unusual for a study of anything to
pursue to produce results of a hundred
percent I mean that that's remarkable is
it or I'm missing something oh you're
very much missing something Tucker for
starters that man's role as an advisor
to Stanford University was news to
Stanford who since clarified Gregory
rehgar no is not an advisor with their
School of Medicine and no one at
Stanford was involved in the study as
for that 100% cure rate you should know
they obtained that by omitting three
patients who were transferred to an ICU
and one patient who died and it is very
easy to have a 100 percent success rate
if you just leave out any result that
wasn't too
success nevertheless the very next day
Trump publicly mentioned
hydroxychloroquine for the first time
and has since brought it up constantly
with varying degrees of recklessness I
just hope that hydroxy cleric win wins
what do you have to lose I'll say it
again what do you have to lose take it I
really think they should take it what do
you have to lose take it what are you
doing you're the president not a mean
sophomore trying to pressure me into
doing adderall also in terms of what you
have to lose possibly quite a bit as
doctors are warning the drug can trigger
arrhythmia which can lead to a fatal
heart attack in certain patients and
that is not to say that this drug
shouldn't be studied it should and it is
but the feedback loop between Fox and
Trump has run way ahead of the science
here in just one two-week period Fox
personalities and their guests made
claims promoting hydroxychloroquine
nearly 300 times with Laura Ingraham
even visiting Trump at the White House
earlier this month to advocate for the
drug
thanks to this media frenzy the efficacy
of this drug which should be a
scientific issue has become a political
one anyone saying they want more
comprehensive studies can be dismissed
by the write as a trump hater and if you
argue that we shouldn't make decisions
based on anecdotal evidence rush
limbaugh has a ready response
anecdotally it's been per anecdotal it
just means it hasn't been scientifically
tested in mass numbers but it means it's
working
anecdotally I arrived at work today it
means it happened right anecdotally you
arrived at work today rush but that
alone doesn't mean that everyone arrived
at work today or even though most people
arrived at work today it just means who
you did there is a process for knowing
whether a scientific claim is true and
involves testing and observing results
in a controlled setting rather than
yelling your thoughts confidently into
c3po s penis and I know it is easy to
write off Limbaugh as a right-wing
blowhard but the reality is he draws
over 15 million listeners a week and
the most loyal of whom is the president
who reportedly considers Limbaugh a
real-time metric of how his decisions
are playing with his supporters and all
this time existing patients with
conditions like lupus who have been
taking hydroxychloroquine for years and
now struggling to get it
one large healthcare provider even wrote
to lupus patients telling them that due
to a worldwide shortage
it won't refill their prescription
saying thank you for the sacrifice you
will be making and look I'd like nothing
more than if this was somehow a miracle
cure but I can't say it is and I can't
say it isn't because it's still being
tested and I'm not a doctor it
might it could it's too soon to say the
problem is might and could aren't really
words that grab an audience that is why
cable news often traffic's in bright
primary colors and easy storylines me
telling you that we have to wait for
results just isn't satisfying to hear or
to watch and throughout this crisis Fox
has constantly presented simple
solutions to complex problems just what
Sean Hannity formulate a plan seemingly
in real-time for resuming baseball games
by testing every person in attendance
and having them wear PPE if it's my
choice and I have to wear gloves a mask
okay I'll wear it I'd rather go and wear
it if everyone else is wearing it we can
suck it up for a couple of months until
things have passed probably can't eat
popcorn cuz you have to keep your masks
off the whole time but you probably
could eat a hotdog you take a it opening
up your respirator take a bite and you
chew it under your mask I have to drink
my beer if I'm at a game so if I have to
use a straw and slip it in I'll do that
I would rather have my temperature take
and drink beer from a straw eat a hot
dog by going like this and chewing it at
a mass and not go at all that's my
decision you make yours
now I'm pro-choice are you really I mean
setting aside the pro-choice line you're
right Sean your body your choice I don't
see a single flaw in that obviously you
couldn't eat popcorn but you can
definitely get a hot dog in your mouth
before the virus could sneak in there
that's just science anecdotally I know a
guy who ate
dog wants and didn't get coronavirus so
that absolutely checks out and while
that's almost incomprehensible stupid
you can't deny its good TV the issue is
that the skills required to produce TV
and to govern are very different and
unfortunately we have a president who
doesn't seem to know the difference at
the start of his presidency he famously
told top aides to think of each
presidential day like an episode of a
television show in which he vanquishes
rivals so we have a network and a
president who thrive on division feeding
on one another at a time when we
desperately need a unified response to a
public health crisis and all that brings
us back to the protests that we
discussed earlier hundreds of people
have taken to the streets this week
fueled by the kind of misinformation
that is rampant in right-wing media the
same right-wing media which then easily
covered the protests that they helped
create like this protests popping up all
across America as some fed up folks are
demanding an end to stay at home orders
they got in front in front of the
governor's residence in st. Paul
yesterday they reference things like
president Trump's statement that the
Cure cannot be worse than the disease
except the cure copy worse than the
disease isn't Trump's statement he stole
that phrase from you guys you shouldn't
be crediting him with that he should be
charging with copyright infringement and
like clockwork Trump just a few minutes
after that segment highlighted groups
like liber8 Minnesota tweeted out
liberate Minnesota followed by liberate
Michigan and then liberate Virginia and
all of this is legitimately dangerous
because watching coverage like that
might convince Trump that there's a
sizable portion of the population that
wants to go back to work no matter the
cost but that's not currently the case
66% of Americans say they are more
concerned restrictions will be lifted
too quickly than too slowly and it's
frankly remarkable that number is so
high after weeks of this and
look I get Trump Fox and those
protesters wanting all of this to be
over I do too I want people to be able
to get back to work and to get some
sense of normalcy restored but
for what it's worth I know people have
died from this I also know people who
are taking hydroxychloroquine because
they think it will give them immunity
and I know people with lupus who are
down to their last few weeks of pills
and it makes me furious because
the fact is the fastest way for this to
be over is for all of us to remain
united in this very difficult task but
the only way that happens is if we have
trusted well-informed leadership which
unfortunately we don't instead we have a
compulsive liar constantly listening to
voices telling him that this is nothing
more than that common cold with
potentially a 100% cure available and
that there's already a great plan to
restart baseball even as there's a
swimming pool killing spree that for
some reason nobody's talking about and
while there are no easy solutions to
make this irresponsible media magically
disappear
I guess there's one trick we haven't
tried yet sir so if you'll excuse me
here goes right-wing media did that work
no everything's still a
nightmare well it was worth a shot what
did I have to lose
you